let's say that it would take you ten
minutes to solve this puzzle how long
would it take if you received constant
electric shocks to your hands longer
right because the pain would distract
you from the task well maybe not it
depends on how you handle pain some
people are distracted by pain it takes
them longer to complete a task and they
do it less well other people use tasks
to distract themselves from pain and
those people actually do the tasks
faster and better when they're in pain
than when they're not some people can
just send our mind wandering to distract
themselves from pain how can different
people be subjected to the exact same
painful stimulus and yet experience the
pain so differently and why does this
matter first of all what is pain pain is
an unpleasant sensory and emotional
experience associated with actual or
potential tissue damage pain is
something we experience so it's best
measured by what you say it is pain has
an intensity you can describe it on a
scale from zero no pain to ten the most
pain imaginable but pain also has a
character like sharp dull burning or
aching what exactly creates these
perceptions of pain well when you get
hurt special tissue damage sensing nerve
cells called nociceptors fire and send
signals to the spinal cord and then up
to the brain processing work gets done
by cells called neurons and glia this is
your gray matter and brain superhighways
carry information as electrical impulses
from one area to another this is your
white matter the superhighway that
carries pain in
from the spinal cord to the brain is our
sensing pathway that ends in the cortex
the part of the brain that decides what
to do with the pain signal another
system of interconnected brain cells
called the salience network decides what
to pay attention to
since pain can have serious consequences
the pain signal immediately activates
the salience network now you're paying
attention the brain also responds to the
pain and has to cope with these pain
signals so motor pathways are activated
to take your hand off a hot stove for
example but modulation networks are also
activated that deliver endorphins and
end Callens chemicals released when
you're in pain or during extreme
exercise creating the runner's high
these chemical systems help regulate and
reduce pain all these networks and
pathways work together to create your
pain experience to prevent further
tissue damage and help you to cope with
pain this system is similar for everyone
but the sensitivity and efficacy of
these brain circuits determines how much
you feel and cope with pain this is why
some people have greater pain than
others and why some develop chronic pain
that does not respond to treatment while
others respond well variability in pain
sensitivities is not so different than
all kinds of variability in responses to
other stimuli like how some people love
rollercoasters but other people suffer
from terrible motion sickness why does
it matter that there is variability in
our pain brain circuits well there are
many treatments for pain targeting
different systems for mild pain non
prescription medications can act on
cells where the pain signals start other
stronger pain medicines and anesthetics
work by reducing the activity in pain
sensing circuits or boosting our coping
system or endorphins some people can
cope with pain using methods that
involve distraction relaxation
meditation yoga or strategies that can
be taught like cognitive behavioral
therapy for some people who suffer from
severe chronic pain that is pain that
doesn't go away months after their
injury should have healed none of the
regular treatments work
traditionally medical science has been
about testing treatments on large groups
to determine what would help a majority
of patients but this is usually left out
some who didn't benefit from the
treatment or experienced side effects
now new treatments that directly
stimulate or block certain pain sensing
attention or modulation networks are
being developed along with ways to
tailor them to individual patients using
tools like magnetic resonance imaging to
map brain pathways figuring out how your
brain responds to pain is the key to
finding the best treatment for you
that's true personalized medicine